hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast point-of-care testing why
knowing now matters the emergency
department presided by dr. Ellis Jacobs
we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
for more information please go to www
scom I'm Christina julik lab roots and
of your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located at the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button the lettuce know
that you having a problem this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CD
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I
would now like to introduce our speaker
dr. Ellis Jacobs dr. Jacobs received his
BS degree in chemistry and Natural
Sciences from Muhlenberg College in
Allentown Pennsylvania and then obtained
a PhD in biochemistry from the
University of South Carolina he did
postdoctoral training in clinical
chemistry and toxicology at the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
dr. Jacobs was a laboratory director at
the Mount Sinai Hospital Bellevue
Medical Center and henry j carter and
cooler Goldwater specialty hospitals for
over 25 years and has extend
experience with poct critical pair
testing laboratory consolidation and
automation computerization and automatic
result recording and planning and
performance of clinical higher trials
for various main laboratory and poct
systems he has over 60 peer-reviewed
publications and textbook chapters and
was the principal investigator on
several beta site studies for various
poct analytical systems dr. Jacobs has
been involved in establishing clinical
diagnostic regulatory and accreditation
standards at the local national and
international levels he is a former
director of the New York state
laboratory accreditation program and is
active in the clinical and laboratory
standards institute his chair of the
clsi expert panel on point-of-care
testing and was a member of the
development committees for EP 18 and EB
23 additionally dr. Jacobs is a past
member in current observer of the u.s.
technical advisory group for ISO
technical committee to 12 on clinical
laboratory testing and in vitro
diagnostic test systems dr. Jacobs was
the aacc liaison to the connectivity
industrial consortium for POC testing I
was secretary and chair of both famsa
and the point-of-care testing division
he was a member of the NACDL MTG on
point-of-care testing committee and is
active an international federation of
clinical chemistry he is past chair of
the communications of publications
division was on several ifcc committees
and working groups please join me in
welcoming dr. Ellis Jacobs I will now
turn the presentation over to him dr.
Jacobs thank you for that
very kind introduction Christina one
other point I do want to make that I am
currently the director of scientific
affairs for el aire diagnostics and had
been working with them for a little over
two years now in helping them expand the
utilization and implementation of
point-of-care testing as you mentioned
in my introduction cive been involved
with point-of-care testing for over 30
years and in that time frame I've seen
point-of-care testing being used and
misused in many ways and that's why the
name or the ton of my presentation is
knowing now matters because it's only
when knowing now matters that
point-of-care testing should be used if
knowing now doesn't matter if a good
meeting sea of results do not have a
value then point-of-care testing is not
the appropriate tool to use what I like
to do today is first go over some
emergency department facts and figures
talk about some of the issues associated
with provision of clinical services in
the emergency department and then go
into three key areas of where Noel
matters one for chest pain to for sepsis
and three for infectious diseases here
are some emergency room statistics from
the CDC in 2011 there were over a
hundred and thirty six million visits to
the emergency department in the United
States roughly two-thirds of these
patients get seen in less than an hour
which is really pretty good we can't
forget that one of the big changes in
the Affordable Care Act is that hospital
reimbursement is now closely tied to
patient satisfaction so longer delays to
see a health care provider will result
in lower satisfaction scores not as well
as taking care of issues associated with
health care directly and that's also for
long emergency department stays and we
can see that twelve percent
approximately own spent less than an
hour emergency
apartment where the majority were
several hours notice in this statistic
that one out of four emergency
departments now have an observation or
clinical diagnosis unit also one out of
three going diversion and that's where
the emergency department is full the
ambulances have to go to another
hospital and when that happens they lose
admissions but we can't forget that a
major source of admissions to a hospital
is through their emergency department
roughly one in five Edie's have
increased treatment of physical space in
the past few years and another one in
five intend to do so in the next two
years so we see that there's a lot of
changes and a lot of pressures on the
emergency department more recently in
2015 it was reported that approximately
three quarters of the emergency
department physicians have seen
increases in patient visits since
January the year before additionally
we're experts are saying that a natural
sorta to primary care doctors and a lack
of physicians willing to accept Medicare
patient is also contributing factor to
increase emergency room usage and
finally in a ACEP american college
emergency physician survey the seven out
of ten respondents said that their
emergency departments are not ready for
the continuing and potentially
significant increases in volume we know
that delay in the emergency department
leads to poor outcomes time is an
association there is an association
between waiting times and short-term
mortality and hospital admissions one
study document said if the ED left this
day is greater than six hours that
patient is 71 27 up for some more likely
to die depending on how acutely ill the
patient is of course compared to the
same patient who's Ed lentes de is less
than one hour
there's another study excuse me that
shows that there's an association being
Hospital overcrowding and mortality and
that for every hour that an ED patient
waits for attention by a healthcare
provider the risk of death increases by
twenty percent and finally a one-hour
increase in overall length of Ed stay
increases the risk of death by ten
percent long ed stays lead to worse
adherence to the ACA accha guideline
cares for and STEMI patients this last
study is part of the secondary analysis
of the crusade registry there are number
of treatments recommended by accha for n
STEMI patients and those who had a
longer bread than eight hours day were
less likely to receive the guideline
recommended treatments and similar
patients who had a shorter stay less
than four hours in the emergency
department we know that lap turnaround
time can impact emergency department
operations in this theoretical study
investigators created a simulation model
to predict it the emergency department
performance measures in an urban ed that
in annual census of approximately
fifty-five thousand patient visits they
are able to model the ED operations
based on laboratory turnaround time and
then all the accesses in in the four
graphs you see here the x axis is the
simulated turnaround time whereas the y
axis is the analyte or metric being
described so we have diversion days
greater than 90 days diversion hours per
day average patients seen per day and ed
length of stay and what we notice in all
four grazie at approximately 40 minute
turnaround time
the graph either plateaus off on a
decrease or its entry plateau off on the
increase and so it appears at 40 minutes
is really the optimum turnaround time to
have the most significant impact upon ed
operations again whether it's diversion
education scene length of stay or
diversions hours per day it's important
to note that 40 minutes is probably the
best turnaround time that most clinical
laboratories can meet using their main
laboratory equipment but that is from
the time they receives a sample to the
time that the report it and that's
different than the brain to brain
turnaround time which is what's being
looked at in this theoretical
description and is also what most
clinicians think about they're not
worried about the time going to hitting
the specimen hits the lab door do they
get the result back but they're worried
about the time from either when they've
ordered the test or when the sample has
actually been drawn to get the result
back so the probability is that the that
point-of-care testing can turn around
the results faster and that is really
the case for point of care in the
emergency department faster turnaround
times when implemented with changes in
processes and procedures can lead to
better ed operations which could lead to
better ed outcomes so with that
move on to specific areas and let's
first look at chest pain according to
2010 CDC report in 2008 there
approximately 60 1.7 million non injury
ed visits of which five and a half
million are nine point eight percent
were people presenting with chest pain
all those individuals that presented
with chest pain we see that eighty-seven
percent of them received a diagnosis
other than acute coronary symptoms and
another study showed that for patients
that were 45 years or older when they
were discharged from the ED nonspecific
chest pain was the most common symptom
thus while we associate heart attack
with chest pain in the ED in fact it is
very often not the case however since
heart attack can be lethal ed physicians
must consider it for all just paying
patients and we know that chest pain is
not a specific Naga Gnostic symptom well
again while we associate chest pain in
the ED with heart attack that chest pain
could be coming from the heart and not
be a heart attack also it can be coming
from the gut other chest organs muscle
bone etc so there's a variety of reasons
why person could be having chest pain
and not having a heart attack and
similarly and stemming non-st elevated M
eyes are not limited or diagnosed by
chest pain to complicate matters further
chest pain is not the only symptom of a
heart attack in fact the chest campaign
could be as mild as Chester discomfort
or shortness of breath and other
symptoms of n stem ease our poor
diagnostic tools sweating nausea
lightheadedness and so forth can be
attributed to many causes so there
really is a diagnostic conundrum here
and to complicate matters even further
almost half of the chest pain patients
get to the ED within four hours of the
onset of their symptoms we've done a
very good job of educating the public to
take
seriously unfortunately this now makes
it even harder for us to determine if a
chest pain patient is having a heart
attack or not the bar markers of cardiac
necrosis may not have had a chance to
rise to detectable levels also that may
not be severe enough for long enough in
duration to cause the other classical or
overt heart attack symptoms like
shortness of breath radiating job thing
cold sweats and etc the emergency
department has to make a rapid decision
of where to dispose of that just being
patient because as shown earlier delay
its leads to bad outcomes it's a chest
pain ischaemic in origin [ __ ] the cath
lab be activated could this be an
earlier in mind which the patient should
be held for observation is the risk of
mi low enough to discharge the patient
or should they be admitted for further
evaluation the conservative approach
would be to hold all chest pain patients
in the ED until your 100% sure that it's
not a heart attack or to put them into
observation or to admit them and that
might be the safest way to go but it's
really terribly inefficient we have to
remember that eighty-seven percent of
those patients are not experiencing an
acute coronary syndrome the ed has to
make the right decision with a high
degree of confidence while being as
efficient as possible with their time
and resources and a key piece of
information to help make this
disposition are the cardiac biomarkers
in 2000 the European Society of
Cardiology in the American College of
Cardiology redefined mark re infarction
this new definition of mi shifted the
MIT opponent Kyle away from the older
relatively high receiver operated curved
cut-offs roc cut-offs to the much lower
99th percentile normal patients
equally important this definition of mi
requires that there be a troponin level
above the 99 percent top with signs and
symptoms of ischaemia we cannot forget
that the definition has been amended and
refined since then and the most recent
guidelines in 2002 defined myocardial
infarction as cardiac cell necrotic
roses as indicated by the rise and or
fall of cardiac biomarkers presumably
troponin with at least one reading above
the 99th percentile this must be
accomplished by symptoms of ischaemia
and/or handful other criteria and we can
see the symptoms you have symptoms of
ischaemia new presume significant st
wave and so forth the important thing is
that we have now decrease the
concentration troponin for this
diagnosis significantly excuse me now
what is this changing cuff actually mean
it means that a positive troponin is no
longer an mi it means that a positive
ponen means cardiac damage and that
cardiac damage could be caused by
ischaemia which is a heart attack but it
could also be caused by a myriad of
other conditions and here's just a small
list of the non ACF excuse me non heart
failure conditions that can cause
elevations that your opponent to
detectable levels and some of these
conditions make sense like cardiac
inflammation and they ordered section
and others are a little bit surprising
like innovation we further we now know
that endurance athletes marathon runners
have elevated levels
troponin after our race and thus a
detectable level troponin no longer
equals a heart attack so how's the best
way to use your opponent I results well
at the troponin levels are in the normal
range in other words below the 99th
percentile then the chest pain is
unlikely to be cardiac in origin again
remember that eighty-seven percent of
chest pain patients in the ED will not
have an ACS diagnosis as the assay is
still using an ami cut off and the
troponin levels are above that cut off
then it's fairly likely that that
individual is having a heart attack and
if the Japan results are between the
99th percentile and the am I cut off the
guidelines recommend the use of cereal
drawers to help differentiate between
cardiac damage that is caused by the
cute event and a chronic cardiac
condition the patient is having a heart
attack then the the troponin level
should rise over a few hours and if it's
a chronic cardiac condition then the
troponin levels are likely to stay
stable unfortunately clinical trials for
modern troponin assays do not lend
themselves to the establishment of the
ROC cut off based on the boot criteria
the EDS must routinely run serial
drawers to establish temporal changes in
cardiac biomarkers and the guidelines in
literature denied you give the time
intervals and the delta troponin
criteria for these yet they're working
on that as we go to more more sensitive
troponin eyes we see studies coming out
of Europe and elsewhere that are talking
about one to three hour rule out
criteria because of the greater
sensitivity of the troponin a say that
they are using but these have not been
well defined and there are no assays of
that type available in the u.s. at this
time the American College of Emergency
vision that physicians guidelines were
stemi elevated chest pain patients
didn't give some guidance on how to use
your opponent's and to the older
biomarkers myoglobin and ck-mb if the
patient has experienced chest pain for
greater than eight hours an agency KMD
your opponent excludes mi and that could
be troponin i or T patients presenting
less than eight six to eight hours early
presenters can be evaluated using serial
drawls and multiple markers and here
negative myoglobin in conjunction with
negative ck-mb at baseline in 90 minutes
or negative to our delta ck-mb mass in
conjunction with the negative to our
Delta troponin so it's very important to
remember that all assessments of chest
pain patients have to beacon done in
conjunction with patient signs and
symptoms all the cardiac biomarkers are
clear as an aid in the diagnosis of
chest pain patients not for making the
diagnosis the strategy of the ACEP takes
advantage of the fact that after the
onset of an mi the cardiac biomarkers
rise quickly and this graph is a drawing
to illustrate this fact we do have this
colored area of the troponin line we
really don't know yet exactly when
troponin levels rise with the more
analytically sensitive assays but we do
know that you're putting levels are
detected earlier than 46 hours after an
mi on set with the high sensitive
troponin assays now here's data for one
study that shows what can be achieved
with a serial draw protocol this
retrospective study was conducted to
three Dow fossils which at the time
conducted draws at one two or three hour
intervals testing for troponin i see 8
km b and myoglobin using the alert
triage platform the protocol was to
consider a patient positive for MI if
with signs and symptoms consistent of mi
the troponin was greater than point for
on any draw
the ROC cut off the my 11 doubled
between draws and add posted detectable
on any draw or the myoglobin doubled and
the sea can be increased by fifty
percent between draw regardless of
whether teeth troponin was attacked
detectable or not knowing that the
criteria by which troponin guys who were
being interpreted for EM I changed the
investigators also analyze their data
using only the troponin data at the
older ROC based cutoff of 0.4 and the
best approximation of our 99th
percentile for the triage to run an
assay of point zero five this slide
shows that the sensitivity specificity
and predictive value after opponent only
with serial or single draws using both
the point four and the point 05
thresholds and we see that bailar excuse
me we see that by lowering the threshold
to 0.5 in both cases that the
sensitivity of the assay increased
significantly from the high 60s from 68
to ninety-seven percent from 57 to
eighty percent so we saw exactly what we
were expecting you see an increase in
sensitivity however the problem is that
this improved sensitivity came at an
expense of the positive predictive value
positive predictive value one from
eighty-seven percent to thirty-seven
percent in the case of single draw from
89 to thirty-six percent in the case of
cereal draws so we've now see that we
have very high trust in a negative value
negative predicted I was ninety nine
point four ninety-nine point nine
percent so it was negative you had very
good confidence that it was negative I
ever it was positive we weren't sure
what that really meant and one way to
compensate for this is to combine the
information for of troponin with that a
ck a and B and myoglobin and when that
was done and we looked at over 5,000
patients and over 30,000 results that
were generated there was an overall
diagnostic accuracy in ninety nine point
seven percent so now we had the same
high negative predictive value as with
it her ponen alone but now with the
positive predictive value was able to be
increased almost up to ninety three
percent so we were able to compensate
for the increased sensitivity and non
specificity of the increase your poems
by throwing in both ck-mb and myoglobin
however what does that really mean
here's another study that showed the
operational benefits that can be
achieved using a rapid disposition
protocol using the same protocols that
were just shown at the dallas hospitals
in the previous couple slides in this
case this was done in New York City at a
major academic hospital and they
developed what they called the race or
the rapid acute cardiac evaluation
pathway in this hospital any suspected
ACS patient was sent to the telemetry
unit for monitoring and the emergency
departments physicians hypothesized that
the volume of the missions to their
limited pool of telemetry bed was one of
the main contributors to prolong ed
let's stay for patients being evaluated
by or for acute coronary syndrome they
further hypothesized that by utilizing
the race pathway they would be able to
reduce a number of admissions to the
telemetry unit and thereby reducing the
ed let's a stay for those that were
being admitted to the telemetry unit as
well as for those being discharged and
this data shows that
when they implemented the race pathway
that the hospital lets us stay for the
race patients decreased by approximately
twenty-six percent uh excuse me by
twenty percent twenty-six percent were
discharged directly home and now it's a
major cause for that overall length
hospital at the state decrease but we
also it's interesting to note that in
the ED Lessa stay even the non race
patients had a significant decrease in
their emergency department lets us take
the race patients had some but it was
not did not trigger a statistically
significant factor and the hypothesis
there was that by bleeding off those
patients via the race protocol with
twenty-six percent gum being discharged
home and 55 / 10 admitted directly to
general floor that the demand on the
telemetry units for all patients being
sent there whether they were being sent
there through the race protocol or the
non race protocol was less and therefore
they're able to be seen and had care in
the telemetry unit better so even though
the protocol was applied to raise
patients it actually positively impacted
all patients in the emergency department
overall with this implementation there
was a twenty percent reduction in
hospital in sustained a thirty three
percent reduction in emergency
department length of stay and a
sixty-two percent decrease in the 30-day
mortality of these patients
sorry something happen with my screen
okay sorry about that now it's very
important to understand that simply
introducing point-of-care testing for
cardiac markers is not really sufficient
to improve ed operations in this study
conducted for hospitals point of
character funnin testing was used for
half the patients and regular lab based
testing was used for the other half as
expected we see that the turnaround time
for the foot for the to fund results
with point-of-care testing was much
better than that of the lab from little
under an hour to 15 minutes and in
addition to percentage of results that
were available in the to the physician
that were available in less than 60
minutes went from fifty three percent to
almost a hundred percent with point of
care and those that were available to
the physician in less than 30 minutes
went from three percent to almost eighty
seven percent these are very impressive
changes in turn around time and in
getting the results back to the
physician in a prompt manner however
they had no significant impact on ed
operations for those patients that that
were being admitted the time to
disposition decision was only reduced
approximately eight minutes and time did
the Parker was reduced by nine minutes
and those patients were they were going
to be discharged home the time to
disposition was increased by 20 minutes
but again the time to actual departure
or action upon that was only reduced by
seven minutes the authors concluded that
the impact of the improved turn around
time of point-of-care testing on Ed
operations has to be considered in all
ed operations in order to take advantage
of it if you don't take advantage of it
if you don't change your processes and
just getting the results faster doesn't
necessarily help you and this has been
shown in many other studies not just in
the emergency department so now let's
take a second or two or three and talk
about emergency room and sepsis and why
knowing now matters sepsis as we know is
a very serious medical condition caused
by poorly regulated immune response to
infection it's comprised of a complex
chain of events involving inflammatory
and anti inflammatory processes which
can result in a variety of presentation
symptoms fever decreased core
temperature elevated heart rate altered
Mental Status abnormal white counts with
increased immature forms hi pearl
academia and increased plasma
procalcitonin in severe cases acceptance
one or more organ fills and the worst
case scenario is a continuing decline of
overall health including a decrease in
blood pressure weakening of the heart
septic shock multiple organ system
failure and eventual death the incidence
and mortality incenses has been on the
rise primarily due to an aging
population increases of chronic disease
and the spread of antibiotic resistant
organisms as well as an upsurge and
invasive procedures and broader use in
impressive and chemotherapeutic agents
sepsis remains the leading cause of
death in critically ill patients in the
United States each year over 750,000
people will develop sepsis and almost a
quarter million will die this mortality
rate eclipses aids and breast cancer
combined in 2002 the Society of critical
care medicine published their very first
surviving sepsis campaign guidelines and
their goal was to elevate clinical
awareness of sepsis and improved
diagnosis and treatment with the initial
goal of reducing septic mortality by
approximately twenty-five percent the
dialogues have been updated several
times and the most recent ones were
published in early 2013 the diagnostic
criteria for substance requires
evaluation of five basic physiological
areas general symptomology inflammatory
response abnormal white counts CRP or
procalcitonin hemodynamic variables
blood pressure organ dysfunction looking
at Arturo hypoxemia acute on urea Ilyas
thrombocytopenia and tissue perfusion
they look at capillary refill and
they'll also look at lactate which
happens that's part of the metabolic
pathway when oxygen is decreased in its
concentrations or when there's an
aerobic glycolysis taking place lactate
was identified as a key marker
perceptions because it's produced by the
tissues that are lacking oxygen we also
know that sepsis related mortality is
worse when lactates are elevated in
addition to offering or defining the
diagnostic criteria for sepsis to
survive and such as camp
also established guidelines for the
treatment and other performance
measurements like antimicrobial therapy
infection prevention and instructions
source control they the campaign
strongly urges the implementation and
defined protocols for their treatment of
patients suspected of sepsis especially
those with blood pressure that remains
high after administration of IV fluids
for its lactates are very high the six
our goal is to normalize the blood
pressure improve your an output improve
oxygenation of the tissue and does lead
to a normalization of any elevated
lactate normalizing the lactate or
lactic clearance is associated with
improved patient outcomes to be able to
make fast decisions regarding patient
care point-of-care measurements of
lactate including serial measurements
may be useful and more speed than
central laboratory testing now there's
good evidence that the surviving
substance campaign protocol can work the
mortality improvements of the study here
may seem modest but this is data is
pulled over 250 to sites and it's
difficult to know how well all 252 sites
are able to strictly be here to the
protocol yet we do see an unadjusted
mortality decrease from 37 to 30 point
eight percent over two year period
studies that single sites can compare
compliance with diagnosis and treatment
bundles with outcomes and here this
study at the Mayo Clinic shows that as
subtle as sepsis bundle compliance Rose
sepsis related mortality fell the went
from as bundle compliance went from 13
to fifty three percent mortality decline
from thirty to twenty two percent and
then finally in this third study we see
even more impressive results mortality
of the septic patients that were not
managed by surviving substance diagnosis
treatment protocols was over sixty
percent while those that were managed by
the same surviving sons bundles that
drop to 20 percent very very significant
improvement in patient outcome by
implementing the survivors protocols CMS
now requires that hospitals report on
several metrics related to their
substance identification control
protocols it's become that important of
an issue they want to know how quickly
and how consistently hospitals are
executing important diagnostic and
treatments for septic patients and
hospital to have poor metrics will agile
see a decrease in their reimbursement
from CMS a 2010 study in the Journal of
emergency medicine found that
point-of-care testing provided a
reliable and feasible way to measure
lactate at the bedside some studies have
suggested that bass excess is an
accurate marker for the prediction held
elevated lactate in the ED however some
studies also show poor correlation due
to the effect of other conditions on
base excess point-of-care lactate is
useful in the diagnosis of sepsis at the
bedside and is recommended for
institutions where clinical decisions
are limited by lack of laboratory
infrastructure or reliability also
remember that lactate levels rise
quickly when the blood sits in the tube
for any length of time and by doing
point-of-care lactate you remove that
variable from the situation the
surviving sepsis bundle suggests that
serum lactate must be available with
rapid turnaround time within minutes to
effectively treat severely septic
patients an arterial blood gas analyzer
located in the clinical laboratory
usually accomplishes this hospitals
should make sure to invest in adequate
equipment to meet present standards of
care for septic patients if a central
analyzer is not efficient in a
particular hospital setting
point-of-care analyzers should be
evaluated for being able to provide
faster
around time the purpose here was saying
don't forget about creatinine well we're
talking about the need for rapid
point-of-care test creatine definitely
can fall into that area especially when
we're talking about the need to be able
to identify individuals with poor renal
function prior to having any type of
contrast dye administer to them contrast
stars are very real toxic and if they
don't have good renal function uh then
you could actually put the person into
renal shutdown and we don't want to do
that so plenty care creatinine can also
play a key role but again unless you
have done something to identify the fact
that you're getting the result faster
and change your systems and protocols to
react to the faster create and result
just getting that fast will not
necessarily improve your operational
efficiencies and now I'd like to go into
the third and final area to talk about
and that is why knowing on matters it in
infectious diseases in the emergency
department there are many advantages for
rapid testing for infectious diseases we
have better directed therapy we have
medical guidelines that outline the
specific drug to give with specific
pathogens and without understanding what
pathogen the patient actually has
doctors often rely on broad-spectrum
drug choices rather than specific drug
choices and that can then lead to
increase want to stay because of poor
treatment of the patient we understand
that antibiotics don't just kill
pathogens they also killed the commensal
normal microflora so we have to be
careful about adverse consequences if we
give antibiotics and we can actually
induce c difficile infection in the
patient because by getting rid of those
normal protect
flora we allow the the nasty bugs to
grow reduce lenses stay in the emergency
department timely application of
appropriate infection control procedures
either apply them when necessary and not
applying them when they're not necessary
and of course teachable moments to be
able to affect patient care and talk to
the patient or the patient's parents at
the time about what they're going
through if it's a viral disease to
explain why they are not giving
antibiotics to the patient if it's you
know and that they should be given
antivirals so there's many advantages to
rapid testing in this study and these
were pediatric patients there were
almost 200 patients seen in the ed and
they were tested with a rapid flu test
the result of the rapid tests was shared
with after the best itions to see how
the knowledge would affect their
behavior when the fluid test was
negative there is no effect on behavior
and that's not surprising since we
really don't know or extremely since we
know that the medical professional still
does not know what is causing the
symptoms so they'd still have to do
blood counts cultures dipsticks x-rays I
may give antibiotics like we were just
talking about you may give antivirals
but it's not selected so having a
negative flu result doesn't really
change it however when they got positive
flu result we saw that it became an
actionable result and it had a very
significant change in behavior and a
direct clinical impact when the doctors
were aware of the plasma through tests
they ordered fewer tests they order less
antibiotics they've ordered more
antivirals because they knew what it was
and therefore they were able to be
selected in their follow-up
calls and treatments so again when it
was negative there was no change when I
was positive there was a very
significant change and this made a
significant advance onto operational
metrics again when the flu is positive
we saw that the laboratory radiation
charges uh decrease from 92 to fifteen
dollars per patient and look that when
the time to discharge went from 49 to 25
so there were very significant impact on
cost and time to discharge length of
stay and again longer they stay in the
ED the more negative it is and again we
saw that when the fluids negative
because they weren't sure whether or not
the patient did have flu but it was a
false negative result or they had
something else that there was no change
in the cost of laboratory radiation
charges or time to discharge because
they need to do other things and they
still need to work out that patients
conditions the problem with most of the
rapid flu tests is that that they're
poor sensitivity is due to a difficulty
in clicking a good clinical sample and
the best illogical test out there cannot
compensate for a poor sample molecular
methods do address that issue by Apple
find it and that helps make molecular
tests sensitive while at the same time
maintaining their specificity the Alara
I test system provides a sensitive
specific rapid influenza test that
facilitates timely action by the
clinician and with this assay the doctor
can be confident
the positive and negative results and
this slide shows how our rapid molecular
test compares to traditionally
commercially available PCR or methods
and we see that we have a ninety four
point eight percent pasta percent
agreement and a 97.7 percent negative
percent agreement with flu a and with
flu be we have a 98.4 and 99.4 positive
and negative percent agreements
respectively mathematically positive
negative percentages the same thing as
sensitivity and specificity but we
cannot use the term sensitivity and
specificity because that's only when
you're applying it against a gold
standard or the absolute diagnosis of
the disease PCR is not the gold standard
actually for flu right now the gold
standard for flu testing or influenza is
a culture so if we're doing this against
culture we will talk about sensitivity
and specificity because we're doing this
against PCR we talk about positive
percent agreement or negative percent
agreement but regardless this shows that
this methodology is is very comparable
to traditional PC our methodology and in
fact we say that the aware I has the
fastest turnaround time of any of the
tests on the market whether we're
talking about the other wrapped of
molecular systems a little bit better
our molecular systems conventional pcr
or viral culture whether it's for
influenza or strep bay that snake of the
case is the same and patient
satisfaction is often related again that
to the amount of time they spend in the
emergency department and treatment
decisions are directly related to the
ability to get diagnostic test results
in a timely manner so this system that
allows for high performance near the
asian and it's also able to be triaged
and portable so it's very advantageous
in 2006 the Center for Disease Control
Prevention publisher recommendation that
HIV screening be performed on all
adolescents and adults in areas where
HIV prevalence was greater than point
one percent effectively stating that all
adolescents and adults should be tested
for HIV and they also removed a
significant barrier to testing by
recommending an opt-out consent in other
words patients could be screened for HIV
unless a request not to be previously
HIV screening required the patient's
explicit approval to be tested so that
has changed it significantly there are
more recent CDC guidelines since this
one actually jun 2014 but this MMWR
still current as the guidance on which
populations to be tested the 2014
guidance just goes into a gorilla alta
test not to whom to test the policy
statement for the American College of
Emergency Physicians regarding HIV
testing mirrors that of the CDC
recognizing the benefits of early HIV
testing and treatment and recommend
screening for all adolescents one
important point here is that the key
benefit of emergency department HIV
screening and that is all HIV screening
too for that matter is the ability for
the program to link newly diagnosed
patients to resources within the
healthcare system to manage and limit
further transmission of their disease so
is rapid testing in the ED feasible
there are several pros to it high risk
populations use the emergency department
as their sole source for medical care
seroprevalence is relatively high and a
fourth and outstanding opportunity
rapid tests are quick and accurate and
there is a growing experience and body
of literature that demonstrates a
clinical and cost effectiveness of it
the negatives of it funding living a
comparison data a program implementation
will vary depending upon resources and
psyche I used to be the director at
bellevue hospital center in new york
city and one of the locations that we
did our rapid HIV testing was actually
in the mental bathhouses in lower
manhattan so we would actually as well
as in the emergency department so we
actually went out and tried to apply to
very unusual sites where we knew that we
would have the best opportunity to
identify or get you those individuals to
agree to it there are some negatives
associated but many of their perceptions
as we know perceptions are not always
true but perceptions are more important
than reality so they do have to be
addressed but there are many benefits of
early diagnosis of HIV infection
reduction of high-risk behaviors
reducing the risk of for transmission
and allowing individuals with HIV to
seek treatment earlier which will then
improve their health reduce the risk of
premature death and also reduce viral
load which then reduces the risk of for
transmission for screening in the ED you
want to wrap it easily implemented HIV
tests and simply put the alero determine
condo HIV test detects more early
infected patients than any of the other
rapid tests available and we are
comparing it to rapid test now so in
conclusion is point-of-care testing in
the emergency department cost effective
absolutely there's some very nice review
articles covering the value of
point-of-care testing for acute coronary
syndrome Vigneault thrombolytic advanced
set the stroke
and these are two quotes with respect to
the numerous manual steps to perform and
transferring a blood sample to the lab
and retrieving the results that total
cost of point-of-care test devices
cannot exceed those of the central
analysis and when use effectively and an
appropriate context point-of-care
testing has been shown to reduce delays
and treatment initiation in critically
ill patient elevated cost of
point-of-care / analysis seem to be
outweighed by the total gain of
expedited patient flow in the
appropriate setting the last point
alludes to the fact that we can't think
of financial silos yes the laboratory
budget may go up but if it increases the
butt or decreases a budget elsewhere by
having impact upon Ed left to stay
having impact upon ICU recovery time
having impact upon decrease with amount
of blood products that are being used on
that individual we have to look at the
cost as a whole and not to cost per cost
Center and third and most important you
have to make sure that structural
changes procedural changes have been put
into place to take advantage of the
rapid result again as we've seen time
and time again that just throw a result
at them faster does not necessarily
change how the patient flow is you need
to make sure that they can actually
utilize that fast result in a timely
manner to have a positive impact on
patient care or flow so then closing
point-of-care testing has been shown to
be an effective tool in the emergency
department healthcare armory it does
require training it does require
oversight and it does require planning
but if done appropriately the benefits
can be significant and that is why we
say that knowing now matters in the
emergency department with point-of-care
testing thank you very much
dr. Jacobs thank you for that
informative presentation now if you have
a question you'd like to ask dr. jacobs
place your so now just click on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
your questions will be answered via
email I would like to once again thank
dr. Ellis Jacobs forms presentation dr.
Jacobs you have any final comments for
our audience yes again I doesn't repeat
the same thing that I said at the very
beginning of my presentation unless no I
now matters do not employ point-of-care
testing point-of-care testing is an
appropriate tool when used appropriately
and it's not a tool that should be used
in all cases there's a premium that
you're paying to be able to provide a
result through point-of-care testing for
that speed in which you can get the
result and only pay that premium if it's
a value to you so I'm a very strong
advocate and proponent of point-of-care
testing I have been for many many years
for over 30 years now but I do also know
when point-of-care testing is not the
appropriate tool so be judicious be
appropriate and you'll be successful
thank you thank you once again dr. Ellis
Jacobs now before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing your
februari 2017 you will receive an email
from lab roots letting you know when
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announced with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now and we thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye